okay good morning everyone we'll call to
the
capital budget oversight committee
to order
go ahead
i thought i was i thought i was cheering
us
no
the time being 10 15. i'll call to order
the capital budget overview committee
um
for members of the committee this is
being live streamed so when you speak if
you could press the button on the
microphone and let it go
out so that everybody who's watching can
hear you it's the only way they can hear
you
first order of business is the
acceptance of the minutes of our
november 9th 2021 meeting was the will
of the committee
senator senator reagan moves to accept
senator hennessey
seconds is there any discussion on
the motion see none all those favors
signify by saying aye aye
the eyes have it and the minutes are
accepted
um
we have no old business new business rsa
dash a colon 29
dash b cannon mountain advisory
committee commission excuse me
cap
22-01 department of natural and cultural
resources requests approval of the
recommendation of the canada mountain
advisory commission to implement the
canon mountain aerial tramway and ski
area capital improvement project as
outlined in the request dated january 8
2022 to be funded by in the amount of up
to four hundred thousand dollars by the
canada mountain capital improvement fund
is somebody here from
to explain the item
good morning
my name is chris marino i'm the chief
administration for the department of
natural cultural resources
and good morning my name is john devivo
i'm the general manager at canada
mountain ski area and franconia state
park
go ahead and explain the the item for
members of the committee
thank you the item before you is the
track rope relocation
and bollards repair for the aerial
tramway itself
the track cables are what the carriage
assembly rolls on when transporting
the two aerial tramway cars
up and down
every 12 years by manufacturer code
and through the new hampshire tramway
safety board we are required to
move or relocate those track ropes so
that the
pressure is not always in the same place
at the same time
we do have a a plan and a desire to
either do an overhaul on the aerial
tramway or a replacement that would be
off in the future 2023-24
and so the manufacturer and the state
tramway board have recommended that we
complete this project again as we are in
that 12-year timeline
thank you
questions from members of the committee
senator hennessey
thank you i'll move it
sarah hennessy moves the item is there a
second
uh representative bucco seconds the item
further discussion on the item
see none
all those in favor signify by saying aye
opposed nay the item is approved
chapter
228-11 laws of 2017 transfers
cap22-002
department of administrative services
requests authorization to transfer 690
dollars from completed health and human
services security upgrades chapter 2811
b five capital project to state-owned
buildings security upgrades chapter 20
228 colon 2b4 capital project as
specified in the request dated january
14 2022.
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee my name is karen rantamackey
i'm the director of plant and property
with the department of administrative
services
the item you have before you
requests to transfer some funding 690
000 which is the balance remaining in
the account
from one security upgrade project which
was designated for
specifically for the health and human
services building at 29 hayes drive
to
another project which is available for
security upgrades at other
state-owned buildings
in new hampshire
the reason for this request is
that the projects at health and human
services have been completed and we're
now looking to do
an installation of central air
conditioning on the lower level of the
state house as a security measure
there was an incident several years ago
where a window air conditioner was
removed and someone was able to enter
the building through a window
and we believe that installing the
central ac will render the building more
secure my basic question is who
authorized
the installation
of air conditioning in the state house
at all is there anything from a capital
budget
facilities committee or is this this
the
commissioner deciding that the state
house needs air conditioning
this is a project that
was initiated through the bureau of
general services
working with facilities
over at the state house doug del chino
and terry pat
but
my basic question is is there a formal
approval of
putting air conditioning into the state
house by a legislative committee that
oversees budget and dollars
not that i'm aware of
at this point
i'm not sure what the committee wants to
do
i personally have a problem with
authorizing projects that have not been
vetted through the
legislative process in some fashion
whether it be a statutory
committee or
the capital budget at least the
facilities committee should have been
involved with this
i'm not sure what the committee wants to
do with this bill i know what i would
want to do with this item i know what i
would want to do
senator hennessey
thank you mr chair so i do recognize
that there is a safety issue with this
because once you put the air
conditioning units in the windows are
not locked
and so somebody can easily get in from
the outside would you prefer that this
goes to another committee before coming
to this committee for approval
i would prefer that at least go to the
facilities committee
for them to look at what it is what the
cost is
and where the money comes from rather
than just us going oh well the
commissioner has
decided that we're going to start with
the 690 and then try to find the rest of
the money that's needed
mr chairman
sign of the waters
i think for that second question about
whether this is sufficient for the
project we could ask
about that
i
personally think this is a good project
to do
and i would support it
if it goes to
facilities
fine but i hope that that is an
expeditious
project
this committee has often
transferred
funds
it's the committee that does it
rather than waiting for the capital
budget to come around
uh in another year or so and in light of
the other upgrades have been done to the
state house i think this is in line with
what we're trying
to do i can think of a couple of first
four
offices where there's security issues
and also in terms of the visitor center
there's some issues with some valuable
property there as well so anyways i i
hear what you're saying i understand the
importance of process here but i do
think we're a committee that's
constituted to be able to approve such a
request
and that's just my feeling about it
and my response would be that
in my experience on this committee for
the last decade plus
those transfers have been made to
complete existing projects not establish
new projects just because there was
money left over
but what is the will of the committee
okay
sorry okay
so should we maybe table this item
and refer it to facilities is that you
know it would you maybe that would be an
appropriate
you know in your opinion if you can
state it
that would be
my preference is that at least have the
legislative facility general court
facilities committee look at this and
bring it back to us with
what they intend to do
how they intend to fund it because
i know that facilities
within the legislative system has some
funds which may be enough to complete it
or not
i'd just like to hear a lot more
information about it
but again i'm only one member of the
committee so
it is up to the committee to decide
senate
senator daniel savannah i'll get back to
you
thank you mr chairman is there a time
sensitivity to this
to you mr chairman do you know how long
it would take if we sent it to
facilities before we'd come back
no i'm not even sure at this point who
the chair of the it's probably the
speaker and the senate president but
no i don't have any idea
representative phuko
thank you mr chairman mr chairman
apparently there's a million dollar
surplus from other security projects
that's
what would be happened to that money if
we hold this up
that money stays
um there
because it was in the capital budget
and
and it stays there until
the next capital budget is approved
so that they could come back any time
over the next year or so
to say that they want to use it for
security upgrades or other purposes
or even this same purpose
it doesn't just automatically disappear
but now that it's been highlighted
everybody knows that it's there for
um
for use in other projects
mr chairman i move to table and refer
this to facilities
thank you senator
daniels
moves that we table this item
uh until our next meeting and refer to
facilities uh
for
uh their input
is there a second
scene none it dies for lack of a second
what is the will of the committee
remove the item
senator hennessy moves the
the
item
uh
22-002 is our second
senator reagan uh seconds it
is any further discussion on cap22-002
see none all those in favor signify by
saying aye
opposed nay
okay let's
go ahead um it in my my
quick
listening it looked like it might have
been a thai vote
i would ask
[Music]
i apologize
uh okay starting with representative
bucco
your yes all right
senator regan
all right
senator daniels
senator hennessy
yes
senator waters yes
okay uh representative claudia the clerk
vote yes
okay uh let me see anybody i think
that's okay mr chairman i'm sorry
no okay
the result okay your vote quickly one
two five yeses two no's the motion the
item the emotion
uh with majority vote item cap
22-02 is approved
that is our final
action item for this meeting
there are a couple of informational
items
cap
21-024 from administrative services
on quarterly capital budget report
and then
from the department of environmental
services status of the one stop project
are there any questions or comments on
the informational items
yes
i notice a lot of them are roofing and
boiler projects and i'm wondering
why they're on hold and what the status
of them is going to be moving forward
i'm happy to speak it's not a report i
normally speak on but i am aware of the
projects at least the administrative
services projects not the other agency
projects
we have a lot of projects ongoing right
now
in addition to the capital projects
that were approved for the current
biennium we have projects that weren't
able to be completed during covid which
are also capital projects and then we
have arp funding that's come in um
allowing us to do additional projects so
it's really just a matter of workload
right now we're trying to spread it out
so we don't burn out the employees that
we still do have because we are also
dealing with some staffing shortages as
well
thank you
any further
questions or comments seeing none i
would like to propose
that our next meeting be march 28th
which is a monday
it is after
at least on the house side after our
last reporting
requirement for the before crossover
crossover is that com the thursday after
that march 31st
hopefully the senate would be finished
with their hearings and reporting by
that monday
we get it out of the way before we start
getting inundated with the bills from
the other body
so i would like to propose that we meet
march 28th at 10 15 in the morning is
there any objection to that for planning
purposes
see none that's it
and i would close
adjoin this meeting of the capital
budget overview committee and i
appreciate everybody coming for a
relatively short meeting but
if we wait and let things stack up
things do not get done thank you all for
being here
you